well ronnie go away from the court for a
second um zlatan the
soccer player said that he believes that
famous people and athletes such as
yourself shouldn't use their platform
to do anything other than what they're
good at in their athletic endeavor
as someone who has promoted the idea of
more than an athlete and trying to
empower uh players to
to use their voice to speak on their
communities do you have any response to
what he said
no absolutely not i mean because at the
end of the day um
you know i would never uh shut up about
things that's um
that's wrong um i preach about my people
and i preach about
uh you know equality um social injustice
racism um you know systematic uh
voting uh voter suppression um things
that go on in our community
because i was a part of my community at
one point and seeing the things that was
going on and i know
you know what's going on still because i
have a group of uh
300 plus kids at my school that's going
through the same thing and they need a
voice
um and i'm their voice i'm their voice
and i use my platform to continue to
shed light on
everything that may be going on not only
in my community but around the uh you
know this country and around the world
so
um you know if
there's no reason uh well no obviously
no reason but there's no way
uh i will ever just stick to sports
because i understand how
um you know how this platform how
powerful my voice is
um and he can just ask uh renee
montgomery uh you know if i would have
shut up
and just dribbled um seeing that
beautiful black woman today
um you know be a part of a group
where she's part of our ownership group
now with the atlanta dream down in
atlanta
and uh it's funny he say that because i
believe in like 2018 he was the same guy
who said uh when he was back in sweden
talking about the same things um because
his last name wasn't a certain last name
that uh he felt like it was some racism
going on when he was out on the pitch
um right he didn't say that right
yeah i thought he was i thought he said
that so um
i speak from a very educated mind so
i'm kind of the wrong guy to actually go
at because i do my homework